hello everyone I really enjoyed my
previous job I love games so I decided
to do another video and this is his own
favorite game so he says in an interview
I will put a link to this interview in
the description below the injury is from
2014 but he does mention this game as
being one of his favorites and also the
entire interviews pretty great so you
can check it out as well the game was
played in 2003 it was the Euro club cop
and he's playing against Afghani but I
have the same Afghani bear that had that
that terrible moment of playing Bishop
to a seven against Karpov in Linares
1994 so I'll definitely have to do a
video where Barry wins the game and like
we see in the quote above the board this
entire game is home preparation by job
Allah which is quite fascinating and I
will tell you why when I get to that so
Japan has the white pieces and he plays
efore and for those of you who played a
classic variation of the caro-kann this
game could be actually quite instructive
c6 the caro-kann by Barea d4 d5 and
Knight 2d 2d captures on e4 Knight
captures on d4 on e4 and Bishop to f5
Knight to g3 attacking the bishop bishop
to g6 and h4 h six now Knight to f3
Knight to d7 and h5 spassky's variation
Bishop to e7 now Bishop to d3 Bishop
captures Queen captures on d3 and Knight
G to f6 Bishop to d2 bishop for is a
maybe a bit more active Bishop to d2 is
also all right we have E six queenside
castle by Joe baba and the Bishop to e7
Queen - E - now we have kingside castle
and King to be one getting the King out
of the dark square so any Bishop to g5
future ideas won't be possible and after
Queen to a5 the king is already
protecting the a - pawn
we have c5 and this is the
the critical and the beautiful moment of
the game like I said it's fascinating
that this entire game so job Allah says
is home preparation because here's Obama
plays a normal response would be
something like D captures on c5 or maybe
Knight to e4 immediately but he played
d5 completely offering upon and what
black is definitely winning upon here he
can either accept the pawn with the
night or with he captures on d5 and
there was another game played in 2003
where Knight captures on e on d5 was
played followed by Knight to e4 and
Queen to b6 and white really struggled
for a draw in this game so it's really
amazing that in this position bara have
decided to play he captures on d5 and
what's even more amazing that Gabala had
planned for / f2 to go for the inferior
line and he plays it Bishop captures on
h6
this is his home recipe we have G
captures on h6 and Knight to f5 and here
we here here we see the true idea behind
he captures on d5 when the knight went
upon captured on d5 it's no longer
defending the DF v square and now the
knight is attacking the bishop on e7 and
also the pawn and h6 so probably a move
like well if you want to defend the
bishop probably you can't really defend
it I mean but the brave tries a better
move would be something like King to h8
you can't defend this Bishop but okay
rook to e8 and it's interesting that
this is also something Jabba had planned
for Knight captures on h6 and here we
have King to f8 if you play something
like King to h7 this this loses
completely to Knight to g5 check and you
can't capture the night on h6 if you
play King cat version h6 Knight captures
on f7 loses the Queen with the royal
court and if you play something like
King the g7 then Knight H captures on f7
comes with a temple on the Queen also h6
is coming this is devastating
so after night to h6 would check bar F
played clink to f8 and here we have
Knight to g5 Queen to b6 and Queen to f3
Knight to e5 is played with a tempo on
the Queen we have Queen to g3 and thus
Queen to g3 comes with a terrible threat
if Blackpool were to play a slow move
for example rook a to d8 this loses
immediately tonight to h7 check which is
the main threat only move as Knight
captures since the King can't move and
Queen to g8 is checkmate
so after Queen to g3 we have Bishop to
d6 now Burrell is creating an escape
route for asking
so night to h7 doesn't work now but we
have nice - f5 now blocking the e7
square from the king and again this
night to h7 comes as as a threat queen
capture some b2 as this is the only move
possible any other move loses the game
immediately so queen capture some b2
with check a job always forced to
capture the Queen King captures on b2
and now Knight to c4 opening up a
discovered attack from the bishop to the
Queen we have king to b3 now Bishop
captures Queen and now not capturing the
bishop but Jabba plays h6 pushing the
passed pawn forward as you know past
points must be pushed and here we have
Knight to a5 check if you would try to
save this bishop although it's not
really worth saving anymore for example
Bishop to e5 after h7 you you do have to
stop point h8 somehow probably night to
h5 rook captures and Bishop to h8 no
blocking but after were characters on d5
a wise position is simply too dominant
so after this after this h6 idea bereft
ride Knight to a5 would check here we
have king to a4 and beriev tries
something here he plays b5 with check
giving up tonight we have King captures
on a5 and our Bishop the c7 would check
King capture some b5 rooked
v8 with check came to a four we have
nice to e4 now rook captures on d5 and
Knight to c3 with check now King to a
three and of course not capturing the
rook because this pawn is becoming a
queen so tonight the b5 check again kink
the b2 now Knight the d4 a discovered
check from the rook King goes to c3
we have nice the b5 check here if you
play something like Knight captures on
f5 to remove the defender of the e7
square this doesn't help black well not
really after night to h7 check King to
g8 and now Knight to f6 check King to h8
and simply Knight captures on e8 you win
the rook you are also attacking the
bishop on c7 you're attacking the knight
and f5 this is completely winning for
white so after King to c3 bar I have
tried night the b5 with check and dr.
King to d3 and now there are no more
checks from the knight or from the any
other piece and in this position
Afghani buddy resigned at the game and
well as much as as much as it is a
beautiful game it's to me it's even more
fascinating that the entire game was
home preparation especially since Barea
played that he captures on d5 and not
night night capture 75 which like I said
already one game was played this year
and Knights capture some defy was played
so I mean how much does how much does
this get prepare for for a game it's a
quite amazing so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon